what is the purpose of the corporation
this is one of the most controversial
and perhaps one of the most important
questions that we need to address in
this course and that you will need to
address as the next generation workforce
leaders why is this the case well
because American CEOs have answered this
in two different ways from the 1940s
through the 70s and 80s and into the
1990s there was a broad view of the
corporation that is now narrowed down to
focus on maximizing shareholder value in
the short run here's a quote from the
CEO of sonesta hotels roger sanan belt
he says social responsibility and
expanding profitability are not at odds
with one another quite the contrary
there are two faces of the same coin
that view was shared by a lot of CEOs of
his era best illustrated perhaps by
graduates of this important institution
called the Harvard Business School the
class of nineteen forty nine is known
for producing enormous number of CEOs
that spread across the economy over the
next decade or two many of them have
been veterans of World War two in fact
ninety percent went to the harvard
business school on the GI Bill many of
them were first-time college students
and their families many of them grew up
during the Depression and they were
imprinted by the hardships of that time
as well as a commitment to community
service that was embedded in them during
World War Two so they had a particular
view of their responsibilities let's
start with an example from one of the
best-known companies of the 1950s
through the 80s Xerox one of the
companies it was a pioneer high
technology company led in the
development of office products and it
was led from nineteen sixty eight to
nineteen eighty-two by Peter McCulloch
one of those graduates of Harvard
Business School class of 1949 Peter
McCulloch graduated and went to work at
Xerox worked his way up through various
managerial capacities
CEO in 1968 Xerox was located in
Rochester New York where they had
manufacturing operations and mcculloch
believed very strongly that the role of
the CEO was to be a good corporate
citizen in the community he worked very
hard to improve education to build
strong community colleges which then
provided a very competent workforce for
his organization and for others in the
region he worked on local and national
politics he worked closely with the
labor union that represented the
manufacturing employees at Xerox they
were among the first to develop for
example quality of working life programs
and quality circle improvements to
improve productivity and to compete with
growing international competition in the
1970s and 1980s and in particular he
believed very strongly at developing
talent from within the organization and
particularly led the way for developing
talent among women and among minorities
within Xerox so it's not an accident
that in 2002 and became the CEO of Xerox
one of the first women to rise to that
level of authority in American industry
and it's not surprising than in 2012
that when an retired the first
african-american CEO of a very large
fortune 100 company Ursula burns
succeeded her and the culture carried
forward the same view of corporate
social responsibility can be seen in the
words of these CEOs as was the case with
Peter McCulloch so if you look on
Xeroxes social responsibility report on
the web you'll find currently the
current the same words that mirror what
McCulloch stood for quote since our
earliest days Xerox has embarked on a
never-ending journey to demonstrate that
good business and good citizenship are
not only compatible but are synergistic
the report then goes on to talk about
customer satisfaction innovation via
patents community participation
avoidance at work for
injuries and so on employee
participation in community affairs all
as part of what they believe are the
responsibilities of the modern
corporation this was the dominant view
not only of Xerox during this time but
also of other corporations best
illustrated by the statements of the
Business Roundtable the largest
corporate association of executives from
the 200 largest companies in the United
States and as late as 1990 the Business
Roundtable made the following public
statement corporations are chartered to
serve their shareholders and society as
a whole the interests of shareholders
are primarily measured of course by
economic returns over time the other
stakeholders in the corporation are its
employees its customers its suppliers
its creditors its communities where the
corporation does its business and
society as a whole and all of these are
vital to the long-term economic
performance of the corporation that's
the view up till around the mid 1990s by
this time business is convinced that it
should focus on shareholder value and so
the Business Roundtable says in our view
the paramount duty of management and the
board of directors is to the corporation
stockholders the interests of other
stakeholders are relevant only as
derivative of the duty to stockholders
the notion that the board of directors
must somehow balance all of these other
stakeholder interests fundamentally
misconstrues the role of the directors
and the responsibilities of the
corporation well this is a big change
what caused this change well it was a
revolution in ideas about the
corporation that came largely from the
academic literature of the time the
leading finance professors of the time
Fisher black and Bob Merton at MIT and
their colleague myron scholes at the
University of Chicago had developed a
formula for better ways of pricing
options that is shareholder stock so
that you could use stock
options to compensate for CEOs their
formula made it easier to use these
processes and then colleagues at the
Harvard Business School published a
number of papers saying we ought to tie
shareholder value to CEO compensation
through the use of stock options and you
saw the role of stock options grow you
saw the CEO compensation grow from what
used to be about a ratio of 30 to 1 that
is the CEO earned about 30 times the
average employee in the firm to today
where it's well over 300 to 1 well what
was the consequence of all of this one
of the examples that we could turn to as
another venerable company Stanley Toolz
a company that was a household term
because of every tool box in America had
good wrenches and other tools made by
the stanley corporation in Connecticut
it was a very socially responsible
company until the Board of Directors got
taken over and someone said let's really
focus on shareholder value and so new
CEO was brought in place and started to
lay people off not as a last resort in
economic ness because of economic
necessity but as a pre-emptive step to
try to boost shareholder value more and
more companies did that and in fact that
led New York Times reporter Lou you to
tell to write a very well-known book
called a disposable American basically
chronicling how American corporations
changed their behavior over time did it
really benefit shareholders all that
much well if you look at the data the
data show that shareholders got about
the same rate of return about 7% in the
old stakeholder era as they were getting
in the shareholder era if you adjust for
some of this restructuring in fact their
rate of return goes down a little bit
from the previous time period so we've
imposed a lot of costs on society but
have we really benefitted the
shareholders as the theory might suggest
that's a question that you will have to
answer the era of maximizing shareholder
value in the short run is still with us
does this work for the future does it
work for your generation that's a
question that you will need to address
as you shape the work the work force and
the corporation of the future
you